[Music]
hello everybody thank you so much for
coming this is gonna be where should I
run my code let's go got a lot to cover
so quick question how many people here
kind of write code on a semi-regular
basis okay lots of the room maybe 60 70
percent how many people here keep code
running like keep servers running keep
infrastructure running like all the
pieces so kind of 40 50 percent here and
how many people are coordinators of some
kinds managers like P GM's like all
these things and another kind of 20 30
percent so like everybody does a lot of
different things right at the same time
awesome okay so I think this will be
useful for all of us
and it's like where should I run my code
and sorry
it depends uh-huh and hopefully through
the next you know kind of about 40
minutes we'll talk through a whole bunch
of the trade-offs and options so first
this is Google cloud next so we have
blue hexagons if you happen to know what
these are already you're you're good
you're all set the kind of proper names
for the various pieces here and I kind
of put them in this order on purpose
there's kind of a stack and abstractions
tracked how can you get more abstract
and you get more concrete kind of down
at the bottom so we've got basically
compute engine our VMs hosted kubernetes
clusters of running like collections of
containers App Engine which is a
platforms of service and cloud functions
which is you know functions as a service
so you input output and the takeaway if
you if you want to get to lots of talks
at the same time is I'm gonna make the
case that the majority of the time if
your work looks like kind of these
things like you might really strongly
consider starting here and you may
branch out from there and I'll we'll
talk about why we think but basically if
you've already got code that exists and
is running well I'll put it into VM make
it work well if you are primarily
working in containers
hosted kubernetes or kubernetes
somewhere is going to be a really great
choice if you're primarily working with
code that talks to the internet maybe
needs to scale up and down very quickly
over the web App Engine is a great
choice and if you're primarily reacting
to things happening events happening and
you need to do something functions are a
really good choice there so that's the
quickie version and deep breath no
worries
and I'll I'll try to convince you of
that by the end we can move around
between these abstractions so we're
gonna talk kind of bottom-up go through
all those and then I'm going to actually
answer the question where I start on my
code and then give you some ideas of
where to go from here so compute engine
these are virtual machines they are
logically computers the same kind you'd
plug in and use other places but running
in Google Cloud and you can have really
quite large computers these days you
know lots of CPUs lots of memory lots of
disk attached like lots of graphics
processing unit GPUs and tensor
processing units if you're doing machine
learning for this stuff and one of the
things that's really interesting I think
about our VMs is that all of these
pieces are individually configurable so
if you have a workload that is very
memory intensive but doesn't do much
compute or the opposite or needs a huge
amount of storage space you can actually
make a machine that's that size and save
you a bunch of money versus just making
a huge large computer so that's useful
they start quickly for virtual machines
like around tens of seconds so 10 20
seconds per machine and these are
computers so they're running a whole
operating system so we have images built
for various Linux operating systems and
then also windows operating systems and
you can create your own image if you'd
like to run something very specific
perhaps a company image or things like
that diving into disk just a little bit
because I think it's it's an interesting
example and these are available they're
true throughout our our compute but this
kind of really makes it shine our
default disks are all network-attached
storage so they're they're collections
of pieces of disk parts of thousands of
disks across a whole data center and so
when you when you make one larger you
actually your disk just gets faster and
faster and faster as you use more and
more of the data center and it allows
you to take snapshots live copy those to
another machine make a new computer out
of them maybe in another part of the
world
easy backups that sort of thing so it's
as you're thinking about these like
virtual machines feel like computers but
every aspect of it is at data center
scale so your disks your networking your
load balancer all this stuff so I guess
but try to keep an open mind as you're
evaluating the different pieces because
you can make exactly the size computer
you want make it as fast as you need and
change these on the fly including
changing the disk size without rebooting
the machine which is handy if anybody's
ever run out of disk before which I've
done and kind of more than just virtual
machines so we have if you make a
machine that you really like and you
want to have sibling machines that do
exactly the same work you can basically
kind of take that image and make a
managed instance group and say okay I'd
like to have five of those now oh now
I'd like ten back down to three and you
can just have compute engine just scale
up and down and you can even do that
automatically based on load and just a
moment to talk about our load balancer
if you want to dig into the details
there's a paper on it called maglev the
internal name is called maglev and our
load balancers that you're using from
compute engine and all the rest of
products I'm going to talk about today
are actually the data center scale load
balancers that we use to run all of
Google off of so when you're making a
configuration change here it's the same
law of balancing infrastructure which
means it scales up and down incredibly
quickly you can make a new load balancer
and immediately hit it with it's in a
about a minute hit it with like a
million requests per second of traffic
and and then drop down to nothing and it
works so with you as a developer as a
project manager as a team when you're
using virtual machines you're thinking
about your software the shape of the
computer the operating system like what
the networking connections are it's very
similar to kind of
working with on-premise hardware in a
way but just be careful because it's all
software so but you're you're
responsible for all those same concerns
so this is a really good fit for lift
and shift kind of scenarios where you
have existing software you want to bring
it over a non-obvious one if you just
want to run one containerized process on
a computer of arbitrary size that's
really easy to do with compute engine
you can point it at an image and boot it
up and have it go if you have a need for
a really particular version of a Linux
kernel or if you have very specific
licensing requirements this can be a
good or perhaps only fit to do this it's
great for running databases and the like
so and you can do you know I sent nearly
all of the network protocols you'd if
you broadcast we don't do on the
constraint side it takes about 10 to 20
seconds to startup one machine you can
start up thousands in around a minute
that's pretty fast response but some
loads need faster response time so that
might be a constraint and it's
completely up to you to manage the whole
software stack which is important to
recognize you know how you update your
software and alike so what does it feel
like I've been talking for too long
already let's go ok so this is the the
web interface for Google cloud platform
you've probably seen demos on like
before but there's one thing that is
critical to understanding this interface
and it's this button hamburger button
all of the real functionality is in
there to switch between different parts
of it so click on the hamburger button
go find the thing so we will take a look
at compute engine and come over here and
create an instance so we can give it a
name like awesome we're going to make it
on the west coast because we are on the
west coast right now if I can read I
guess we should do it in Los Angeles and
and we can basically choose a whole
bunch of pre-configured machine sizes
but we can including up to Oh in that
region don't have all the biggest ones
but this is where we get to the
customization that we were talking about
so if you want to have a machine that is
exactly 20 cores and not that much
memory or more memory you can kind of
like move these sliders around and
create exactly the shape machine you'd
like if you are doing so different
regions have different base and chipsets
available and the the CPU family so if
you were doing rendering earth or other
processes that need very specific CPU
instructions you can say I need to have
this generation or newer of CPUs and the
like and those do vary a bit by zone and
we can in here choose what kind of just
gets on any of the kind of pre-built
things various Linux's different
versions of Windows Server and the like
or your own and all kinds of other fun
stuff but I'm gonna go ahead and right
before I hit create down here at the
bottom so on the when you're learning
something new like it you want to be
exploring right so the web UI is really
good for that once you figure out what
you want if you do it through there you
can actually click down here and get
either the exact kind of JSON payload to
pass to our API or the command line that
would create exactly the same image so
you can then run this from G cloud and
get the same thing so if I hit the
create button and will start mental
timer going of you know right now we've
actually allocated the resources to run
this machine and are actually kind of
caught copying this image out and
booting the machine up and waiting to be
able to actually run your code so once
it goes green on that check box it's
handed off to a startup script that you
can define to run whatever your software
is on the computer and this is my
favorite button this will actually since
I'm logged in to Google Cloud with OAuth
it knows who I am so it's actually
pushing an SSH key to this new instance
and then it's going to connect me via
the web over you know Jess
Shh into the machine and actually do
work on it so we can take a look and we
can we can have some scrolling text oh I
have to do that as you know it's real I
got an error message and so we have
scrolling text proving that it's a real
computer Oh bounce so that's a quick
taste of compute engine there's a whole
lot there please take a look so why
might you choose compute engine it is
very consistent if you do your testing
on ten VMs in a given zone and later you
want to use those same ten VM somewhere
else you should get very similar but
almost the identical behavior wherever
you run them whenever you run them so it
should be very consistent these custom
sizes live disk resize in other talks I
probably talked in in detail but
basically if you use the same shape
instance for a long time they get
cheaper over the course of a month so
sustained use discounts automatically if
you leave that going if you have batch
jobs we have something called
preemptable VMs so their VMs that are
guaranteed not to live more than 24
hours might shut off at any time but
they're dramatically less expensive to
run and behind the scenes if we were
planning to do any work on the host
machines we actually move the VMS to
another computer without dropping
network connections usually within
milliseconds to do that and it's
naturally a good fit for almost all the
software that's out there currently you
know it's running on computers with
networks between them and that sort of
thing and by the way we do run services
on top of GC ourselves so compute engine
I'm sorry
partly kubernetes engine our cloud
sequel instances and other things are
actually running on top of compute
engine so a lot of what we're going to
talk about later inherits all of these
qualities that we just talked about so
head to the docs all sorts of
information about compute engine there
and there are quite a lot of talks but
here's a few selected talks to check out
for more details about compute engine
for a time and okay so kubernetes engine
as you might guess is kubernetes hosted
on Google cloud so anybody heard of
containers thank you for the laughs
so how many people have heard of
kubernetes though I'd like to get a
sense so like kind of heard the word how
many are using kubernetes in some
fashions anywhere ok quite a quite a lot
maybe 10 20 % that's awesome thank you
so the the quick version of kind of why
containers in in my mind if you ever
heard somebody say well it works on my
machine well I mean containers basically
solve that problem like it actually
works in all the places because it it
has the exact same binary and the same
file system that you use to test and to
validate and you bring that to
production and bring it to the other
machines so that in a short that that's
my personal feeling there kubernetes
comes into play when you have lots of
containers and you want to think about
multiple computers and large numbers of
containers as one system and reason
about it in that way so it is inspired
by systems built previously at Google
and built in the open like released in
public you know 2.1 release and got
dramatically better because we worked
with real use cases with real users lots
of contributions from a lot of different
companies a lot of individuals just
cross over 20,000 contributors the cloud
native compute foundation owns all the
IP it is a hundred percent open source
and at this point runs pretty much
everywhere so it's it's worth looking
into in my opinion but the conceptually
you're thinking more about applications
than computers so logical infrastructure
and the the short version is you know
when you get together with a colleague
and you're trying to explain how
something works you immediately start
like drawing things on the whiteboard
kubernetes is not far from writing
config files that look like those lines
and boxes we had seen yeah Milland text
so it's like it's more fiddly but
conceptually you're connecting the apple
occasion to the database to the you know
back-end service that like runs and
you're actually defining those
connections in config and telling
kubernetes to be responsible for making
that continue to work which is awesome
and then kubernetes engine is hosted
kubernetes so there is some effort
involved in kind of running a cluster
and keeping it up to working to getting
one started for the first time to like
evaluate whether you even care about
kubernetes so if you're doing an
evaluation it really makes a lot of
sense in my opinion to like go straight
to convert any engine you can get one
running at about five minutes and see if
it works for you and the projects you
have and go from there and basically it
keeps the individual computer nodes you
know up to date it updates cover
Nettie's itself does help you with auto
scaling and things like that and a whole
bunch more now so this is a really good
fit if you are running multiple
environments of any kind and you need to
kind of insulate yourself from the
differences between them and that can be
multiple clouds it can be you know kind
of on like in your own machines with a
cloud it can be different dev tests prod
environments that you want to behave the
same but are actually isolated from each
other those kinds of things it does need
in in my opinion here again like good
team communication because we're
actually mixing some of the
responsibilities that have been
traditionally kind of separated you know
security folks the people who own the
computers the people who like are
responsible and software running on them
all of those pieces they they need to
have good communication we you're
probably much better off if you have
source control with config and your your
application data you know the apps that
you write and go through some sort of
build process so that everyone who makes
changes they go through the same process
and end up in a test environment later
production kind of implies it works much
better that way
one big constraint is kubernetes only
runs containers so you do need to get
your software kind of wrapped up in a
container there can be some fiddly bits
around licensing some software like is
license per physical CPU that it ever
runs on so you need to pay extra
attention to
run it in too many computers things like
that and you know maybe some
architectural details if you've got an
app that has really particular needs
about how the pieces of it communicate
to each other might not be a perfect fit
in that case what this looks like in
practice over here on Cabernets engine I
actually have in cooking show style I
have a cluster already deployed and I
have set up a service that is listening
to right now nothing so you click on it
and you get nothing back and if we go in
here this is a kind of Google you know
the kubernetes engine UI for managing
things in a cluster you can also do this
all from the command line and same story
you can get kind of the raw config file
for the actual what we do in the UI so
you can do that programmatically later
and I'm going to create a new set of
pods which are a collection of processes
that have their own kind of they're
doing work and I'm gonna like use an
image that's already built called nginx
and this is a web server if that is very
very popular runs very well so this will
be just a default deployment of of a web
server and I'm gonna leave all the other
stuff default and click deploy here and
basically it's kind of making some
decisions for me like configuring an
auto scaler and kind of a default number
we start with three copies of this
running somewhere in our cluster and
then depending upon CPU load we'll
actually deploy more or fewer pods over
time and this adjusts pretty rapidly
depending on how much usage is actually
getting and so that can be based on CPU
or a lot of other things to actually
scale the pods up and down inside of the
cluster that is already running so and
then separately cluster size can also be
scaled so now if we come back to
services click on this same thing we
have tada a brand-new nginx thing it's
not amazing but
that's a really quick kind of intro that
I think the the main takeaway there is
once you have the cluster up Cooper net
you tell Cooper days what state you want
the world to be in and it's a job to
keep it that way so if one of these
processes dies kubernetes will restart
it if one of the computers that one of
the nodes that committees cluster is
made up of goes away it will be
restarted and basically that lets us all
kind of sleep better at night
is this is the main thing there so let's
go back to the talk so you might choose
kubernetes like I said before it kind of
insulates you from changes of different
environments it gives you kind of a
higher level of abstraction to reason
about but still lets you do almost all
the things you want to do in software
one of the main reasons Google invested
in this kind of technology is to save
money actually
so it'll enables you to pack a lot more
software together on the same computers
without messing each other up because
you have the isolation from containers
you can specify how much CPU and memory
you want each of them to use and they
scale up and down within this set of
machines so instead of having computers
kind of sitting aside in case you get
traffic to them you can actually have
multiple different applications running
in the same space and scale up and down
as needed and save a bunch of money
especially if you're running in cloud
where you can actually change the number
of nodes that you're paying for at the
same time and this the abstraction level
the whiteboarding kind of level is a
real sweet spot for a lot of
communication and for a lot of reasoning
about your systems you might choose
kubernetes engine like I said because
it's managed lets you focus on it a bit
more very quick start automatic updates
good stuff so again check out the docs
first and there are multiple talks here
this is actually only a small fraction I
think we have something like 20 or 30
kubernetes related talks that the event
and some of the things from yesterday
are already online so check those out
and send them to friends colleagues and
the like and moving on so Abba Jim this
is
this is the transition from
infrastructure into kind of developer
focused code so how long can I avoid
saying surrealist let's see oh not very
long that actually wasn't super
intentional but um so App Engine
primarily is made and was made to help
you help your developers which would be
you focus on code and just push that up
and let us handle the rest and it's kind
of sweet spot is things that scale up
and down really rapidly it you know it's
perfectly fine running things with
consistent workloads but it adapts very
very quickly based on actual activity
each of the processes actually run
inside of a container and so they spin
up on our infrastructure very quickly
it's actually been around quite a while
started in 2008 at the time there were
and up until fairly recently there's
been quite a few constraints around the
kind of code you could run an app engine
had to be certain runtimes had to only
allowed certain libraries within those
languages to be used last year we
announced the flexible environment which
is basically app engine managed VMs kind
of running containers in those VMs which
enables you to run a wide variety of
languages completely custom docker
images and alike and just recently like
yesterday I think we announced several
new second-generation runtimes that are
I pension the standard style
but these are the standard er the the
same language environment that you would
get by downloading Python or downloading
nodejs
PHP we're starting with three of them
this is in the coming very soon like
next week or so kind of time frame and
why this kind of all is sudden how did
the old runtimes we used to take a you
know a lot of effort to secure them make
special versions and alike and the the
the key difference is G visor and this
is a recently open source project that
allows you to run untrusted code safely
without a VM of
action between so it's basically syscall
proxy for applications on linux and
let's kind of safe calls through to the
kernel and blocks other calls and it's
running a user land so it's very robust
in terms of being independent from
attacks in the kernel so G visor and and
pieces around this make us confident
that we can run essentially arbitrary
code safely across our fleet and as long
as to move much much faster in updating
App Engine which leads us to a slightly
more complicated space to reason about
so hopefully this is a useful kind of
break down of these three different
environments and some of the trade-offs
there so this talk is a choose with a
choose inside of it but basically the I
don't make sense on its own but the the
two to the left the standard ones are
sandboxed individual processes running
on an distribute set of machines
flexible is actually managing virtual
machines in your project and you can run
arbitrary code you can resize those to
whatever size machine you would like
that sort of thing the second gen and
flexible are using you basically use
Google Cloud api's directly the original
standard runtimes many of them existed
before before the rest of cloud existed
and so they kind of were incorporating
things that are now part of cloud
normally a blob store we just recently
announced a scheduler which is racing
across ervice and things like that so
all those are available to all of our
execution environments now so the new
pieces use those directly and the big
deal for developers in in many ways is
that you can run any Python module any
kind of node.js extension and I've just
write the code the same way you would
write it in other environments and it
should just run so when you're working
in App Engine you are thinking about the
code you're writing HTTP requests and
responses
and versions which I'll demo here in a
second so like but basically you have a
version of your code and then you have a
whole another version of the application
deployed at the same time which is kind
of cool so let's take a look at that Oh
before you the constraints think so
[Music]
it is a really good fit for anything
that is kind of HP request and response
based stateless applications are
particularly easy to scale and I talked
someone earlier if you have applications
that scale very rapidly perhaps from
almost zero to millions of requests
person per minute or per second and then
back down that's a really good fit for
that sort of thing and actually refer
back to this for constraints it's a demo
so let's take a look at this
so the App Engine dashboard looks a bit
like this and I have I have one app
deployed and if we take a look at it all
it does is return an image of lemons
this is a amazing application thank you
for laughing however I have gotten some
feedback that not everyone likes lemons
even though I love this our lemon so
we've actually created some different
versions of the application and they're
all deployed simultaneously and we can
actually kind of poke at the serving
URLs for them directly so this is
actually a cherry dot this site and so
you can actually test and look at and
have people evaluate I have scripts run
against different versions the
application at the same time Wow the
main one is serving a previous version
so that's pretty cool and then when you
decide actually let's check here so we
have options the lemons the current
state how many people like cherries some
cherries or not
how about apples more apples than
cherries and durian oh we have some
durian lovers
just because we're gonna go with they're
in
so what we can do is actually say we're
going to ignore popular opinion and I'm
gonna actually move the the site over to
being a hundred percent durian and then
when we come back to our main site and
new users on the next request they're
going to get this version of the site so
that's kind of a straight cut over but
the really cool thing is that we can
then cut back just as easily so I can
come here and say you know actually
let's go confusingly 100% lemon go back
maybe I will leave this open next time
and then when we refresh we get all
lemons from there on or if you want to
do a percentage of your traffic you want
to test out your new features without
committing to like all of your users
seeing it you can use the same tool and
basically say actually we want to go
just say 30% apples
hit save there and then as we refresh
this refresh refresh refresh refresh oh
you know what I need to use the shift
because caching maybe let's try it go
closing it all the way click see how
smart I am about web stuff
did I not save now we got a saved
probably sorry so you get four extent of
your demo on the fly some of the users
are gonna get lemons some of them are
gonna get cherries thank you so so App
Engine left developers focused on code
we handle the rest great for like web
focused workloads great for variable
load we're serving well over a hundred
billion requests a day on App Engine for
many many users so please check out the
docs there and and various talks and
we'll do the moment for photos and done
a lot of functions okay so this is
functions in the service and functions
you know the abstract sense are a thing
that you give some input and then it
gives some output or has a side effect
right and so this is kind of in some
ways kind of the purest form of code you
just focus on this specific thing you
want to do it's got some inputs it does
something and you get some output
probably probably the it was a little
not obvious to me but one way to the
reason about this is it's it's functions
that get invoked from something
happening in the world so an event
happens so we can do events from a lot
of places including our pub/sub tools
from cloud storage changes from HTTP
requests that come in from somewhere if
you're using firebase from various hooks
in firebase and it is service you know
in the the definition I'm using of
server lists is anything that an
abundant fits this as well actually but
anything that you're doing work for for
money basically so like you're paying
for a unit of work not just reserving a
thing for a certain amount of time so
you pay for some amount of work that
happens so that's roughly the definition
there it has been no js' and javascript
kind of for the last year plus we just
announced that very very soon
Python 37 support will be added and you
can see content
you'd release of new environments soon
upcoming including something that is
worth checking out will be on the blog
over time but the ability to run
containers on top of cloud functions so
you can kind of wrap up whatever code
you have and have that to work so that's
going to be on a kind of a whitelist
sign up early access program so take a
look at that in the future as the
developer you're thinking about events
and the function definition and kind of
what comes in and out of the function
and that's basically it
oops
shall we edit slides on the fly wait
that updated so it is a really good fit
for anything that's event-driven when
you really don't want to think about the
runtime environment you want things to
happen automatically something that may
be a little not obvious is a lot of data
transformation flows really look like
this you just kind of feed them some
changes and it updates other systems
based on those changes so you kind of
have the ETL workloads a lot of people
use and in my mind it's basically kind
of the glue for the cloud you know you
want to connect this API to that API and
they do this other thing as a side
effect it's a really good fit for that
one of the constraints is you pretty
much have to interact via events can be
a HTTP call but via events your code is
in this function level granularity so as
you get more functions you have to
reason about them the system gets more
complicated and figure out how you're
going to do logging and monitoring and
things like that and the quick demo
there is missing there we go so I have
cleverly deployed a function already it
is a very amazing function that
basically takes this request in looks in
the body of the request for something
called message and then returns
returns that so inside of functions here
so you can actually kind of update them
from here
you can get the this is the URL if
you're going to trigger it and create an
event over HTTP if I click on that right
now I'm not actually sending any data so
I get that no message defined response
and if I want to send some data copy
this example here there's a little kind
of in browser testing that you can do
and basically say hello lovely next
folks and hit test and we get a hello
world back-and-forth so I mean really
there's no developer invite like dev
environment it's straight JavaScript if
you want to do it you can also do it
from the command line using your regular
tools but you can do it all through the
web very straightforward and then
connect these together and there we go
so don't you have to think about servers
that's where the server list comes from
pay only for what you use a very
straightforward developer experience and
talks and talks and photos three-two-one
gone okay so where should I run my code
let's get to the actual talk it still
depends but on what okay so maybe in
listening to this and the things I
talked about you already thought okay I
need to check this out or I need to look
at that so awesome and it depends on
several other things that I wanted to go
into a little more detail on this kind
of what abstraction level do you want or
need to be working at what kind of
technical requirements you have for the
language you're using the the way you
talk to it over the network whether it
has licensing or kernel limitations
things like that and then your team your
organization your your colleagues like
what what skills and interests do you
bring to writing software so in terms of
what you think about this is kind of a
summary of the things I talked about
across the different sections so at each
level of abstraction the the way you
think about the code is actually quite
different
so you may decide that actually we want
to spend most of our time focusing on
code or we want to spend most of our
time focusing on how the pieces connect
to each other and that's where things so
that might be a reason you use to start
in a certain place there are certain
technical requirements that will kind of
pull you down the stack if you will so
if you need a very specific kernel
version you're gonna go all the way to
compute engine if you need you know if
you are you want your code to run pretty
much the same across really diverse
environments you're gonna pull you know
kind of lease to kubernetes maybe
virtual machines that's where the thing
when you need you know to run very
specific languages that might get you an
app engine so and there's several other
constraints as you get into the lakes
research and docks that might kind of
push you one way or the other and in
some ways this is this is kind of the
server list break if you will like if
your team is primarily developers and
want to focus on the code and that's
where thing you're probably going to be
in the App Engine and compute and cloud
functions kind of space if you have good
team integration you've got folks who
are engaging in how the systems work
together and like all in on containers
and you want like there's knobs and
parts that you really need to control or
want to control for your business needs
like kubernetes is going to be a great
fit and if you're coming over from
existing things or you know you want to
kind of work your way into clouds step
by step very deliberately you're
starting with VMs is a really good place
to go so compute engine if you're
running in lots of different
environments this this might also do
things so this slides a little funky but
you know there are virtual machines in
kind of almost every environment like
you probably have them at your own
offices maybe on your laptop a lot all
the cloud providers have them so if your
stuff runs in virtual machines like you
can run it in lots of places kubernetes
essentially runs everywhere right now
and gives you a lot of insulation from
the things that do change in the
different environments so it's a really
good choice for that
the work that's ongoing in the community
around envoi sto K native and others
really are beginning to like make a
really good start at the kind of
platforms of service more like focusing
on the absent code and that inheriting
that insulation so that you can run them
anywhere let that you get from
kubernetes so that's worth thinking
about and then if you've got the
functions that are kind of run in
JavaScript or other languages you can
probably move them very easily between
different functions environments so kind
of things to think about like
equivalency if you're already kind of in
one of the other places look at these
pieces or if you're you want to make
sure that you are able to kind of run in
different scenarios think about these
pieces so I mentioned key native here
right what is that it was in the
announcements yesterday but it's
basically an open source project to kind
of help build additional higher level
primitives kubernetes is very much kind
of infrastructure a high level
infrastructure but the infrastructure
project and the key native sto envoi
pieces are kind of helping us like
reason at the applic you know what they
specifically at the kind of like
developer focused code out of level like
all the way up to almost doing functions
so please take a look at that back to
here and here's here's the crux of the
thesis here so why is this no worries I
think the key thing is if you get code
into containers you can run it in all
the different environments and real
systems that's the room here we erase a
it most systems end up running multiple
services multiple different runtimes in
the end they may have some piece of
third party code that only runs in a
particular environment maybe it needs
Windows and it talks to other stuff and
then you have another part that's in
functions because it makes sense from
the from the data processing standpoint
that sort of thing so it's very common
to run multiples of in the same overall
system and if you are doing that please
take a look at both pub/sub and cloud
storage if you if you notice you look at
architectural diagrams or if you talk to
the cloud solutions folks
almost every system will use cloud
storage and/or pub/sub because we we
actually don't have local file systems
anymore or you know as we're kind of
scaling these things up and down like
you need to have good coordination
between the machines you need places to
put data and get it back out so you use
a lot of databases you'll use cloud
storage and pub/sub a lot so take a look
at those they're not the flashiest bits
but they are everywhere and super super
useful so if you do get your code into
containers you can then move it
relatively easily between the different
abstraction levels in particular for
example if you write an app that you
deploy to App Engine flex as a side
effect of doing that it's actually
created a docker image built it and
written that to a registry so you've got
this image that's sitting there and so
you can take that URL and pointa
kubernetes cluster at it and say run
that and it will run you can take that
same URL and put it into the VM creation
UI and run that same image from there so
kind of working down the abstraction
works like quite smoothly going up a
level you may need to do a little manual
work in some places but it should be
quite compatible so if you are already
in containers that helps move up and
down between these abstractions if you
decide you need to later so start with
these this is the too long didn't read
version start with these and then as
needed you can move as necessary so
that's why I believe no worries on that
we've seen be winding down I will
release folks and I'll be hanging out to
the side and then moving out into the
hallway pretty quickly super happy to
hang out and talk thank you all for
coming
[Music]